so JB you you are uh you are a Gentleman
of Leisure is how you introduce yourself
right but to uh to some of us that means
a
pimp um what uh where did you grow up I
grew up in Bowmont Texas uh my mom was
from bont Texas my dad was from Port
Arthur Texas so they about 15 miles away
from each other and uh it's a very
family
orientated uh town and community at had
U but this was the mid 80s so my my mom
and my dad were never together she
married another guy and he was well off
they was everybody worked in the refiner
industry around their uh
petrochemicals and so um like I said
this was right around the crack epidemic
and he got caught up in the crack thing
and so then I moved to stay with my
grandmother and uh and then my granny I
stayed with her like four years old and
you know granny she trying to instill
that wisdom in you that she messed up
with her child so she she got a second
chance so my grandmother was uh a
phenomenal woman and U you know she like
on Saturdays before I could go out to
play I had to read Proverbs cuz she was
really trying to instill wisdom into me
and so um that's been just a recurring
theme of my life reading books I love to
read she was a reader she woke up every
day and read her Bible every day every
day of my life and so when this woman
got
allas then I started to ask some
questions because I heard her prayers
and I heard her pray to be kept in her
right mind and so when she lost a mind
that really
started uh to change in my life because
I started to read I started to have some
questions about religion and then that
led down to the rabbit hole where I had
a complete break from society where I
was just like I don't want to be a part
of this at all and then that's how I
ended up in the Underworld and and uh as
you say like a professional gentleman
leer we do have to be careful with their
word because when they arrest somebody
on TV and he's a sex trafficker or he's
a uh sex offender and he's doing all
these crazy things they're going to call
him a pimp that's what they're going to
call it because that's the way to
discourage or whatever you know so no
I'm not a pimp I'm a professional
Gentleman of Leisure well I mean so many
the you know pimps are the most hated
one of the most hated next to next to
sex offenders you're probably one of the
most hated segments of society in the US
but what I think a lot of white people
or wealthy people don't understand is
what the reality of Life is In The Hood
right and we'll talk about that in a bit
um that's really why you're here oh man
because you have you and I had a great
phone phone conversation the other day
right and uh and I said you you got to
come in here so here you are because
you're based now in in Vegas right I've
been in Vegas but you know I'm still a
little bit nomadic a little bit but I've
been in Vegas for about the past 7
months and uh I'm probably going to be
going to Dallas tomorrow but yeah uh I
love to have the whole racism
conversation yeah we're we're going to
that's going to be the bulk of this talk
but I just want to set a little
groundwork so so you you got introduced
to the game at what age roughly oh I was
28 I was I had I I actually I went to
college uh graduated from college I
worked in Corporate America for 3 years
as a a field service was engineer I was
working for seamen energy and so my
degree was in electrical engineering and
uh so you're educated right come from a
fairly good family great family uh I did
everything the right way growing up to
28 and then like I said I started to
really study some things and understand
that really though my whole life had
kind of been plotted and planned by a
white supremacist about 400 years ago
that he had kind of plotted my whole
life in the sense that I was raised
around a lot of women my I wasn't with
my father uh I I seen him on the
weekends but uh I was Heavy in the
church I was so I was pretty much scared
of everything uh I went to college and I
was about to go through 40 Years of
servitude after college and my whole
life had and when I kind of understood
that and I think a lot of black men are
going through the same thing when you
find out the truth of your culture and
who you really are and what's kind of
been hidden from you then you have a
wall out moment you have a moment where
you like
everybody been lying to me like
everybody's hiding the truth from me and
so you you know you Rebel and see what's
really so cold is that the white
supremacist playing that part too so
when you Rebel then you end up in the
system so it's like this Devil's Ed for
so it's just
like uh coming into all of that
knowledge and then uh so I started to
really study the whole system and I come
across uh experts and um doctors who
were way smarter than me who was really
trying to understand systemic racism and
I after reading all the reading their
books I'm I'm you know a Gentleman of
Leisure I have time to read I'm might
not do a lot physically but like he
saying I don't never get a mental break
anytime you in the streets or in the
Underworld and you take a mental
break it it's over you might you might
be dead you in jail the woman gone
something something F to happen because
you was off your game and you can't
afford to do that because you always got
this Target on your back this is
systemic you know you playing in the
streets you know what I'm saying it's
their job to get you it's your job to
get away you know so you can't afford no
mental breaks I I
think I'll just touch on this a little
bit then we'll get into our talk on
racism but and and and the whole
situation that's going on with the with
our country and probably other countries
too in different ways but
if you grow up in the hood you you a lot
of what I see after doing so many of
these interviews with people from from
these families these these sub these
cultures these you know the South
Central
LA uh
Chicago you know New York's got it every
every almost every big city has it right
Oakland certainly
um people grow up without any role model
without any hope they're not going to
become a nurse like their next door
neighbor did or like their sister did or
their their mom they're not going to
become a a a lawyer a doctor or you know
something respectable like their dad did
because Dad was in
prison m mom's on drugs or mom's working
the streets or mom's doing something
that's not quite you know I'm I'm
generalizing of course but there's not a
whole lot of examples of what you can do
with your life when you're a young man
or young woman like I had like I had a
lot of great examples like oh [__] I
have all these choices which one do I
want which one works for me and I
followed one of them and that led me to
where I where I ended up where I am
today but I see with these with a lot of
the kids I interview a lot of people I
interview they're they never had that
chance they never had that opportunity
right
so these women are trying to figure out
a way to survive what's a woman going to
do to make money you know guys can
hustle guys can steal guys can do a lot
of
things um but a female doesn't quite
have the same options but but her
attractiveness can make her money
quickly but they don't they never learn
how to handle
money this is a white man telling a
black
man how it is in the hood but tell me if
I'm wrong um
the the women never learn the men too
but I think the a lot of the gentlemen
of leisure as you call
yourself understand how to handle the
money how to manage it so that it just
doesn't just get spent on on garbage
right so you guys can at least have a
roof over your head have a car have
clothes have have a nice lifestyle so
you can make more money and and live a
better life is that is that basically
the the pimp game insh there always
exceptions to the rules there some women
who and there's some terrible pimps too
that is always we have to look at the
total Spectrum so you know but generally
if
uh a gentleman says his up in that
position then you understand that your
role is to take care of this woman and
she's coming to you looking for guidance
looking for companionship looking for
acceptance and it's your job to take
care of her and everything that come
with her and so what I'll tell people is
and people talk to I say listen don't
take this woman money if you're not
going to really be committed to what she
asking you to do because she asking you
to be her man she trusting you with her
life she trusting you with her
everything and if for you to not take
that serious or that you just be playing
with this with what she doing she's
risking everything to trust you and so
that's a big responsibility and so uh
and you can see from that standpoint you
can see why a lot of women say no I'm
not risking all that I'm not I rather to
be independent you know and they'll take
all these chances and um and you know
when you say independent I like well who
you independent from what ain't you
saying we originally belong together
it's oh okay well so if you're
independent from me you got to do your
job and my job so you got to work you
working harder you not NE you know what
I'm saying you got to do both jobs so
from that standpoint it's it's a it's a
trap for them too this is the same trap
that the system set because this she's
out here she has to like I said she has
to play both roles she has to think
about trying to save and manage her
money and she have to think about the
job that she has to do now we out here
in Hollywood all none of the profession
profession entertainers work their way
the professional entertainers they go
hire a agent a manager a coach somebody
behind the scenes that has a vast amount
of knowledge about whatever Journal that
they in that's going to give them
Direction so that they can win we don't
call them people pimps we call them
agents managers and Coach but they doing
the same exact thing mhm they doing the
same exact thing and so a professional
lady in the game uh a professional lady
of leisure she's not she's going to look
for someone who understands her and
understands what she's doing and accepts
it and accepts her appreciates her and
approves of what everybody is looking
for that and she can't get it but from
one person cuz the rest of society is
look thumbing her nose on her oh you do
that oh you said you know the average
woman refuses to sell her time and
companionship not sex she refused to
sell her time and companionship and this
woman is getting paid off her time and
companionship she represents a d you
know women women powerful women like
that have always been a threat always
been a threat when you have some type of
power over a man especially you know you
get you know you get into a dangerous
territory you know King James burned a
lot of women for all of that you know
put them on the stake woman had too much
power she had to
go and this has been going on
since since
whenever well I mean Europeans came here
and and there you go since the European
is being in power what we do to the
American Indian right we uh and so we
have to be honest about that so I that's
what I like about you is that you
willing to have an honest conversation
and and and
the generations have kind of of White
America have divorced they self from the
past and they say hey we didn't do it
you know okay but we don't live in a
vacuum the past is connected to the day
so in order to really get deep about
this racism conversation we have to
address the past we can't not address
colonialism that when Europeans came
over here they just had had a free reign
and was like oh every everybody back
home nobody know what we doing we just
going to act fool we going to kill
people rape people and it was no you
know what I'm saying and you think that
that's not going to come back and see
what getes me is you watch Fox News and
you get on the news and they complaining
so much about black and brown
people you don't think you don't think
it's coming back around you know what
I'm saying you you don't think your
actions it's like the naivity to say
that to think that you know in this book
you got it say that the sins of the
father follow to the third generation so
you did wrong your books say that you
reap what you sow and you're not trying
to really make nothing right but you
still complaining about the situation
like you never really gave us no therapy
after slavery you just kind of let us
out after you had already brainwashed us
into your religion then you you know you
say hey well okay and then you can talk
about everything we doing all black
people acting up brown people attacking
the Border well where we learned it
from when you put us in the backyard you
say made us call you master you know
what I'm saying you made us forget all
all our culture all our made us adopt
your way of looking at the world and
then now you blaming us no it don't get
to work that way you know what I'm
saying so uh uh you know I think but at
the same time at the very same time I
still believe America is the greatest
country in the world cuz anybody can
come here and win if you know how to
play the
game and so you know we have issues but
it's still the greatest place and
America is a great country a lot of
people you know you could you could look
at what we did to the American Indians
and that was horrible right you can look
at what we did to the Africans when we
brought them over as slaves that's
horrible and racism still continues but
on on the other side of the coin like
after World War II the United States
could have owned the planet we could
have taken over every single country on
the planet but we didn't we should we
decided not to do that and just let
every country kind of have its own
somewhat Independence and let them do
things the way they wanted to we didn't
take over and you know there's there's
that's seldom talk about talked about
but whatever I mean that that's just the
ups and downs of of the United States
but I still believe in this country and
why that's why I'm doing this project I
I believe in the country but I I believe
that really that the white supremacist
are threatening to ruin everything you
know what I'm saying and I really think
uh this principle of anti-racism I'm
really against it because I think it's a
really bad idea because the uh the
colonial era was hundreds of years you
know what you just talking about this
country is founded on these evil
Roots okay MH and so
um you know the genocide of the Red Man
the sement of the black man so you could
tell Tree by the fruit it Bears so like
if you plant a tree and it's on this
evil like how can you really expect it
to turn into something great you know
what I'm saying you started something
the origins of it is shaky so um the
white supremacist this Legacy of white
supremacy is still threatening to mess
up everything unless we kind of we
really figure it out and have these
tough conversations because you know
they have their ideology and I asked you
about the great replacement
Theory that's something that really
needs to be talked about because the
great replacement theory is the current
generation of white
supremacists who are saying that
basically we feel so threatened that we
F to just start killing people and we we
we going to relive this Legacy of
terrorism domestic terrorism is up ever
since anti-racism came out since 2020
when George Floyd got killed and they
started the big anti-racism
movement which B which basically
anti-racism basically says Hey white
people stop being racist please stop
being racist you know what I'm saying
and we like you know but the thing about
that is the whole world was set
up uh the colonialism and all that
everything was set up this system was
set up so you asking people to go
against their own
self-interest that's not
smart uh with the 48 Laws of Power MH
this guy white supremacist probably hate
this guy hate him for writing that book
because he really put out the power all
the rules to the game so law 13 said if
you need to ask somebody for help you're
not supposed to appeal to their mercy
and gratitude you're supposed to appeal
to their self-interest so if you telling
white people hey stop being racist and
the whole world was set up you know for
them for the for them to kind of benefit
from privilege in certain aspects you f
to have a good fight on your hand
because I study European history anytime
you force a group of white people to do
something it's about to get serious you
know it's about to be a war somebody
going to die that day you know what I
mean so you that's just you know that's
just the history
so I think it's a terrible planetary
chest is based on counter racism so
instead of trying to force white people
not to be racist instead what if we
educate black people to stop falling for
systemic traps and then we can eliminate
systemic racism that way we can say
ho this is a trap the police pull you
over and you don't respect this man and
understand the power situation going
here understand that this man can end
your life right now and he might get let
off the police might not they might not
do nothing to him we've seen this happen
time and time
again and and so understanding that it's
like surrendering at the moment and not
making yourself putting yourself in
position to be killed and say hey okay
Mr L man you got it you got it you know
what I'm saying and I I play I play that
game I've been playing that game since
forever that's what my go that's why I
wear this cboy hat I used to well I used
to drive 1991
Cadillac all over the country and and uh
police used to stop me all the time
thinking I was a dope man I said hey Mr
La man I I'm not the drug I don't I
don't do drugs I don't have no
drugs and I put on this cowboy hat and I
would see the law man you know they he
he got a profile he doing his job I
understand that but when he got up next
to the car and seen my cowboy head it
didn't register in his profile it
said that's not one of the guys we
looking for you know and they would ride
by and I've been wearing a Cowboy head
ever since I said oh yeah this is a
survival tactic you know because I'm
disarming him it's just in that second
on that movie uh the great eight all the
Crazy Eights with Samuel Jackson he said
a [__] not safe unless white folks is
disarmed and my cowboy had this a
disarming tactic CU they say wait a
minute he not one of them type of
Brothers he trying to be like us even
though black people was the original
Cowboys they called them cattle men they
didn't want to be called boy black
people was Cowboys the white man was
called the cattle man you see what I'm
saying so now they say I'll put my
cowboy hat on now they think I'm trying
to be like
them the r you
know so uh no but I've been in multiple
every time I get into it with police hey
how you doing sir oh man listen I'm all
the way in the wrong right now you know
I don't have no license um but I'm just
you know going around oh okay
all right well you spoke to me
respectfully you look like a nice young
man listen just make sure you go
straight home because if somebody else
pull you over you might not be this
lucky it's going to require change on
both both parts and uh I think I think
the change mostly is I think we're
mostly account we have to have we have
to have accountability black people
because we've been seeing the same game
for like we can't keep losing the same
game for 400 years we can't you know
what I'm saying like not understanding
the play and not understanding in which
ways have we won in this strategic thing
and like Haiti of course we talk about
Haiti they uh had a a time where they
overthrew racism white supremacy right
so we have to look back at that and say
well what what did they do what did they
figure out and it's rumored Mr Robert
Green said that they stumbled upon a
copy of the Art of War of
sunzo and then the Art of War sunzo said
says that if you know your enemy and you
know
yourself then you can win any war and he
also says that the Supreme art of
warfare is to defend a is to defeat an
opponent without fighting and so that's
what planetary chess is about planetary
chest is saying that we can end this
thing just by being sharper just by
being smarter and understanding the
whole thing so I want to understand
white supremacy to the total I'm not I
want to understand everything about it
so that's why my research I just wrote a
research paper and the research paper is
connecting the great replacement Theory
to Dr Francis Chris Wilson the color
Chris theory is what her name her theory
was and so um that way we can say hey we
understand what's going on here and then
try not to provoke the white supremacist
you know what I'm saying like goodness
that's why I said anti-racism please
it's bad like leave leave white
supremacist alone like um in 1850 it's a
white supremacist his got his name go
goino uh goino in
1850 he was concerned that it was over
for the white race
then this guy ended up being the father
of the Aryan
Brotherhood so this has been a concern
that um white people was maybe on the
way out and so um explain you explained
on this on you told me this on the phone
call we had this week explain that again
why why the fear in white people kind of
came from oh well okay let's go because
I asked this question to a lot of people
and I said well why do you think racism
started and you know people kind of
dance around the answer but Dr Francis
Chris Wilson she broke it down you know
this is a third generation like scholar
and so what she said was she said when
Europeans uh left Europe in the 15th and
16th century everywhere they went
globally they ran under people of color
red people black people brown people
yellow people and when they start raping
these women and the babies came
out
they this baby not white his baby got
some
color and then they had to start they
said well wait a minute
we can't be too friendly with these
people CU if we too friendly with these
people ain't going to be no more white
people so this is the real conversation
that the white supremacist understands
the white supremacist understands that
we mixing too much you know we got to
look at it from his point of view
because a white woman and a black man or
vice versa has a child 95 98% of the
time it looks like so that's
africanamerican the first thing the the
original gentleman or leer they
understood that they was the first
people to understand that and they
understood that that's the reason that
it was a constant attack on a black man
because you had to separate the black
man from this white woman because if
everybody else you know but it's the
black man the baby definitely don't come
out you know what I'm saying the
definitely definitely got some colored
in so we have to put these brothers in
jail or we have to kill them off when we
can or we have to make them gay as we
can whatever we have to do to make them
dysfunctional and uh make them you know
what I'm saying so they U their family
Union is
disorganized separate divide and conquer
that's the all the number one plan of
any racist attempt has always been
divide and Rule that's the number one
tactic I don't care how far you go back
and look at it from Africa to kid over
here the American Indians it's always
the same in us they use crack cocaine
and poverty and things like that it's
always the same play so the black men
are in prison it's always the same play
divide and Rule divide and
Rule so we got to study that and
understand so like I said if they
they've been running the same play over
and over and over again like at what
point do we say okay well we have to
find some type of way to uh to have some
Unity if they number one Play is
dividing rule then we have to try to
come together and so I see so much silly
stuff like on Twitter uh black people
talking about African people and
Caribbean people and found foundational
black American it's it you playing right
into the you playing right into the Trap
you playing right into it you know it's
divid and ruling all these separations
that's what they they've always done
they always say oh this group of people
is uh Egyptian this group of people is
um Ethiopian this group people wait a
minute wait a minute you know what I'm
saying and they cause so they able to
cause when when the the division then
they sit back and then they wait for the
for the C for the for the chaos that
happen then they profit off off
everything what kind of solutions do you
propose so I I the planetary chess the
way the chess the way chess works is
when you play in chess you don't you you
you you look down and you say we got to
study this game and we got to study
these movements and so we say oh okay
well this is this is the movement he
like to make he's likely to make or we
study certain Tendencies and then we
build up some strategy so but the whole
thing about the game is understanding
your opponent so we saying know our
enemy and then understand knowing
yourself and understanding the game
understanding the total game play and
then once you understand that then you
can you can play chess because and it's
people already playing planetary Chase
it's people already winning and
succeeding you know black people black
it's people who are winning in the who's
not really affected by racism like as
much who enjoying their life and doing
whatever they want to do and so when a
large uh when a large group of us get on
that same page then we'll have some
unity and that's all it's about and then
like all this you know policy stuff you
can't do nothing without Unity you can't
change laws you can't do none of that
without unity and when black people come
together uh then we able to do anything
so that leads to a really interesting
conversation because they gave over $500
million for anti-racism in 2020
everybody you remember mhm everybody uh
we going to donate $100 million to
dismantle systemic
racism everybody was giving money we're
going to donate the guy from uh Twitter
Jack dorsy gave Mr Kendy ibram KY $10
million
for his anti-racism
program and I'm saying okay well I'm
sitting at home because I've been making
films since 2014 trying to educate
people about systemic racism I first
started it's on YouTube and my first
film was called good white folks cuz I
you good white folks you know what I
mean when I say that good white folks if
it wasn't for good white folks we might
still be in somebody backyard you see
what I'm saying so I'm above the racis
conversation but I'm looking at the
white supremacist because I always got
to watch the white supremacist and
that's the elephant in the room and see
anti-racism is not looking at the white
supremacist the it's the white
supremacist who create these uh who
killed people like George Floyd and
create all these different reasons for
you to donate all this money systemic
racism in the individual heart and mind
of a white supremacist are two different
things you can donate money to to the to
whoever you want they don't have nothing
to do with the average racist around the
corner he's still going to be a racist
so you know what I'm saying so you're
not really affecting the problem so
instead of playing this game why don't
you just start educating black people
like Hey listen it's a it's a it's some
white people not all white people but
it's some white people who looking to
kill you whenever they get a chance who
looking to do harm to you you cannot
just be you can just be in the water you
could just be in Walmart with a BB gun
and ain't come in to kill you you could
just be on the corner a 12 year old on
the corner and police come up and kill
you you could just be taking a block a
walk in your
Park a jog in your Park in three-way man
you know what I'm saying so we have to
always know hey it's a war going on out
here you not it's not good it's a war
going on out here and so from that
standpoint we really have true education
cuz we really educating oursel to
survive this is true education so this
what counter racism is counter racism is
saying hey listen you need to keep your
eye on what these white supremacist is
doing and so like I said the interesting
thing is if you could give $500
million to tell white people not to be
racist my project I'm asking for a $5
million investment and I'm saying not
I'm not asking for a handout I'm saying
this is an investment into our
scholarship into black scholarship cuz
we got research I got a research paper
look my you know you can look it up
research paper and all this and that now
if you can give all this money to that
but you can't cuz they I I have a a
campaign I story I told you into the
public relations so I had a campaign I
was pushing out this research paper to
all these go different organizations who
say that they care about ending systemic
racism about dismantling systemic racism
but when I sent him this research paper
and I had to research paper analyzed by
AI so the AI said when they when
artificial intelligence analyzed the
research paper it said this is pivotal
in the field of social sciences I said
it said this mandates a changeing the
conversation so I'm like oh okay I'm
getting I'm feeling myself so I started
sending it off but they they ignored it
they weren't interested in
it how can you have a stated mission
that says you want to dismantle systemic
racism
and I send you a research paper that
talks about the psychological
Independance of racism and connecting
modern racist racist rhetoric with past
Theory theoretical scholarship is what
they want to call it and you just
totally ignore it you don't have nothing
to say at least criticize me and tell me
I'm wrong or something but you just
totally ignore it so that opens the door
to say Can America survive without
taking advantage of black people
can it survive can it survive do must
they um put black people in this place
of uh like you said growing up without
the fathers and this constant slide of
jail or the penitentiary is that
necessary for America to
survive I don't I'm trying to I don't I
don't believe so I don't see how it
would help anything you know what I'm
saying I'm saying that you do better to
empower black people and make it so that
now we understand the traps and we being
more productive and this is good for the
country you know what I'm saying counter
racism educating black people you know
what I'm saying so like that's what my
project is about I'm I'm not concerned
with trying to it's like in chess match
if we playing chess I'm not going to ask
the white side of the chess boy hey man
can you ease up a little bit can you
take it easy I'm trying to get it
together no I'm going to study you and
look at you and figure out your moves
and try try to get ahead of you and then
I'm trying to put you in position where
you can't ignore what I'm talking about
and that's what I kind of did with my uh
public relations thing so I wrote a Blog
cuz I knew that these organizations was
going to pretty much ignore me so I
wrote a Blog every day sending a letter
to these people but I put it in the
court of public
opinion so now I say well everybody got
to see how you was denying This
research and uh I got an article coming
out uh recently from a a media a news
Outlet who decided that they wanted to
air that story so I just want to put
this message out like you know
like this is a great country you know
what I'm saying
you this is a system you gave so much
money saying that this was something
that you was concerned about doing in
the systemic racism okay we got a
problem I'm offering a
solution you know based on Theory and
then in my life I don't think anyone has
more practical knowledge about systemic
racism to me of what I've been of the
situations that have to live in my
lifestyle to to to succeed I've been in
the life I was in the life for 13 years
I didn't spend a night in jail or the
penitentiary or a night in the hospital
even never carried a gun and so
um yeah I don't think nobody have more
theoretical or practical knowledge about
systemic racism than I do and like I
said you look on YouTube got many films
I made a film in September and the name
of the film is called you going to laugh
we [__] up systemic racism because I
believe systemic racism is really on the
way out and a new era of knowledge and
um balance and Harmony is coming to the
world and um and this is a old system
that's really decaying you know what I'm
saying if you look in a country like uh
like England where there are there are
African people of African descent there
but they're
educated and they're much more
sophisticated than what you'll find in
the hood here in the United
States it shows you that that it's
really just a matter of education and
upbringing and Role Models I think that
but I also I get stories to my email
about racism anti-racism systemic racism
and and the reports and racism in Europe
and over it's getting really really bad
is they saying that that it's getting
bad and I mean I guess it kind of
makesense that's probably against Arabs
though that too that too and um
so
um like I said I the think most of the
solution is just being able to have
honest talks and just being able to talk
about it it's like people don't even
want to have the
conversation you know so I really
applaud you just for having these
conversations you know and and just
putting it out
there because it's really something is
is tough yeah it's definitely a big
problem and it's been a problem for
centuries
now but to me the solution is somehow I
mean you know putting in you know
improving the education that goes
on in in poor communities I got a
question I want to ask so what you think
about organized religion's role in all
of this see keep me I stay away from
religion yeah I I don't get involved in
religion that's not my specialty okay
see I mean some people are into that and
let them have their I so that's that's
another big part of of of planetary
Chase because I said is no thy enemy but
is no thyself and when you talking about
self you get into a religious or a
spiritual type of type of conversation
and I'm really a spiritual advisor along
with a gentleman of leion I'm a
spiritual I'm the least religious person
you'll find huh I'm the least so
organized religion and um systemic
racism are based on the same [__] it's
the same fundamental based basis it's a
it's a overwhelming desire to be special
and say oh I'm special I'm special and
every organized religion does that they
say oh you're special you have the one
true belief you know and this is the
same type
of bigotry you know and the same type of
uh bias is created that so somebody says
I'm special I'm better than you and then
we have a war next thing know we got a
war cuz I have to convert you to what I
believe is the truth and this is so like
this organized religion racism white
supremacy which is what same [__] which
is what the what America did to the
Indian and to the that's what they say
that's that that was the Playbook see
nobody ever met Jesus because of his
love and mercy and kindness they always
met Jesus Through The Sword or bought a
gun it was convert or die and now you
still have this America is a Christian
Nation hey this is a dangerous you know
what I'm saying this is dangerous you
know because you create division you
create that Division and as it so turns
out the white supremacist is a
Christian you know so no like I have a
lot of pro you know people have a lot of
issues with me because when I I was very
religious I grew up my grandmother I was
in the church 5 days a week Sunday
school 11:00 service b2u service on
Sunday Monday was uh choir rehearsal us
Bo practice when M Wednesday midweek
prayer service I went to them all I know
the Bible inside and out because I can
tell you about the white man who put the
Bible together and that's what the
church you know what I'm saying the
church need stop come on man the
encyclopedia is open you know we can go
in the encyclopedia and see your
history and see everything that you did
like you know what I'm saying so they
that's really that's the part of the
problem the part of the problem is the
religion creates division along with the
racism and so you you know what I'm
saying but if we're going to change
anything right there's going to have to
be
some some concession on both sides
yeah like you're saying maybe the
African-American Community needs to take
a little more responsibility for solving
problem definitely
need usually the white
Community might need
to well if you want to find out what the
what the core of the problem is you look
at what's the one thing that somebody
doesn't want to give up
power well like money right and the
greed the corporate greed that goes on
here so it's getting worse you know you
look at every company there they're
getting rid of employees left and right
you go to a grocery store you can't even
find a cashier anymore right it's a
machine so they've eliminated all these
jobs and that impacts the poor
communities severely so it makes
everybody you know puts everyone on
their
heels putting more black men in prison
more women are are trying to hustle to
figure out a way to survive right and
keeps the poor keeps keeps the wealth
Gap
growing yeah business as usual the one
thing people don't wealthy people don't
want to give up is their wealth
right um I think all that's accurate but
you know this is an interesting
conversation because I'm into the
Bitcoin and
crypto so when people when I tell people
hey I I developed a system to uh end
systemic racism they look at me like you
know but at the same time Bitcoin is a
computer program and it's aggressively
attack attacking traditional
Finance it's been attacking traditional
Finance one Bitcoin is like $45,000 it
takes
$45,000 to represent one Bitcoin that's
an attack on the financial system Jamie
Diamond and all those people been he was
in the talking to the government the
other day hey if I was you I'd shut it
down because Bitcoin represents an
attack on the on the financial system
you see what I mean and like you say the
old the wealth is changing but we see
this in studying history like I'm a
historian basically and so every
generation have a fight between the old
and the young every generation it's
always a fight between the older
generation and the younger generation
because the views are just so different
right and so that's one of the big
things the wealth the wealth is
transferring because young kids it's
kids who got millions from crypto from
nfts from YouTube
and you know what I'm saying they in the
digital economy on the internet and they
you know what I'm saying sitting at home
making videos getting 500,000 a month or
whatever or $20,000 a
month and so you got this whole paradigm
shift in finance and the global economy
and it's scary it it
scares it scares people but you know
that's just the way it is you know I
think the average I once you the average
length of Empire is around 250 years of
all Empires ever that's ever the average
span is 250 years 2026 make 250 for the
America so you know what I'm saying like
I said take that in account with the
foundation of the roots of which the
country was built on we might be
approaching you know what I'm saying if
we don't get it together we might be
approaching the end of this great thing
so we really have to come together like
you say it's we're going work it out
it's going to require us coming together
it's going to require it but one thing
we can do is we can chill out with the
anti-racism thing cuz we ain't doing
nothing but provoking white people white
supremacist with that we ain't doing
nothing but provoking them because they
feeling already threatened and scared
and then you go don't be racist don't be
racist don't be
racist that ain't sharp that ain't smart
you know what I'm saying leave them
people alone they already on the way out
that ideology is already on the way out
it's a dying thing there's always going
to be an an educated segment right that
are a problem but but they'll become
less and less as and that's what's
happening the rest of us up and uh
unless you stop provoking them and then
you know that great replacement theory
is something serious because what we
know is is they're meeting in these
internet rooms and they hyping each
other up pumping each other up to go and
commit these acts one of uh those white
supremacist guys his name was brevik he
did something in Europe and then he got
online and they write a Manifesto and
they B basically trying to encourage
other white supremacist to do the same
thing and this is what's going on right
now and nobody's talking about it this
idiot R
Swami the Indian guy that's running for
president he got on there something
recently and he says he supported he
actually supported the great replacement
Theory man he's a dangerous
guy he actually a brown a person of
color actually support it the great
replacement Theory and nobody nobody
really battered an eye on that like no
it wasn't big news
and this guy he is playing his role he
trying to get up next to Trump man Mr
Trump he trying to get he trying to get
with Mr Trump man golly you know but
it's just so obvious like come on man
you know what I'm saying like you you
don't know what you like people can't
see see that you know he's just so
blatantly obviously
um he he was and I watched those debates
I missed the last one but I watched
those president the Republican debates
for no reason at all at the end of the
first Republican reverse racism is
racism
what reverse racism is
racism you know what I'm saying that's I
was like no that was unprovoked nobody
even asked you about that for you to say
that but he's trying to prove his
position with white people so much that
he just
totally disregards everything the people
of color is going through and that's
just that's just he's a dangerous person
and U I used to not like Tim Scott but
I'm I I I don't like him because you
know I'm not with the religion thing or
whatever but I kind of agree with him to
a point because I do
believe that systemic racism is falling
it's it's it's it's falling now he go
all the way out there and he say it's
not a racist State come on man you can't
you pushing the line but I think we we
definitely are challenging challenging
that and you know that's scary to a lot
of people too so who knows how it's
going to go man it's interesting times
the most interesting times January
6 man to me that was the Tipping Point
to me that's when I started looking up
that stat about the average length of
the empire
I say wait a
minute white people is the white men is
trying to overthrow the government like
this
is this is crazy you know what I'm
saying like you still it's still what
the senate or the or the um it's still
mostly white men right that's run the
Senate that actually run the country
right and they felt threatened enough to
say that we going to take that we still
don't you know what I'm saying we losing
power so we F to storm the White House
if we don't come together we're going to
fall apart we better simple as that we
better so like I said you you you doing
a lot to just towards having this
conversation is a lot and putting it out
there so I'm real thankful for you yeah
well it's an interesting perspective to
have somebody from from the streets
right well I've I've had you're a
very I've lived every part of the black
experience I grew up in the hood my
grandmother was calling the laws on the
on the uh I didn't grw up in the streets
but I grew up in the hood my grandmother
was calling the laws on a corner house
and I was seeing the police come kick
the door in at 5: in the morning for the
people on you know the the library the
park where where I'm from uh I'm from
it's a little park around the block they
took the goals out because they said oh
it's too much drug activity so they took
the goals down so um I liveed in like I
was the field negro then when I went to
college and I worked at corporate
America I was 25 years old making
$100,000 I went to South Korea as a as
an engineer so I was a field negro I was
a house negro and then I went crazy
and and went off the plantation totally
so yeah I got a perspective because I've
seen like we was talking about root
cause analysis I learned root cause
analysis working at
Seamans in Corporate America so you
understand root cause analysis but you
can't but when it come to racism
we don't we don't understand Ro we don't
want to do no root CA no
more but if it's business they can find
out if a mosquito [__] in the wrong
place and stopped some type
of plant organ something going on they
can figure it out out they going to ask
why 500 times they say oh the mosquito
[__] in the wrong place and it caused
the malfunction and therefore everything
so we have to correct this action make
sure that we put something up to that
this never happened again cuz we can't
lose money cuz we're in the business of
making money so for them to say oh yeah
um U y'all going to be all right or get
over it you know what I'm saying it's
like no you have the ability to kind of
understand this problem but here we go
again we talking about a power thing if
we do recall analysis and we say well
what's the real problem
here the real problem was
colonialism that's what I say
colonialism is the original racism it's
a time where racism was just like they
didn't even know it was called racism
they just was like hey we just doing
whatever the [__] we want to do and here
I don't care how you feel about it you
know what I'm saying and so systemic
racism all I said systemic racism is the
remnants from colonialism so coloni say
hey people say Hey listen we know
colonialism was wrong we you know it was
wrong we trying to do better but what
remains is systemic racism you still
locking black people up at a level more
than everybody else you the police still
k kill black people two times is more
likely than anybody else you see what
I'm saying so these remnants is still
from that original time period so we
still have to live with this and you
trying to tell us oh you know racism not
a problem
what and then the really cold part is
you invented this
system and now this is what I came
across in my research paper so I'm into
the AI thing I kept when I kept
comparing my research paper to the AI it
kept saying something it kept repeating
this one phrase it kept
saying um it's important to recognize
marginalized voices in a racism
conversation I kept seeing it and then
it occurred to me oh this is a
bias cuz the AI is only good as how they
train off so the bias is only white
people can talk about racism you're not
supposed to be able to talk about this
[__] regardless of the fact that I'm the
one experiencing it day in and day out
out I'm not supposed to have no I'm not
supposed to have a definition of it and
that's the the really cold part about it
is you invent the system but now you say
oh no no no this is the definition of
the hold on you don't get to invent this
and Define define what it is you going
to tell the people that's going through
it that don't they can't Define what it
is no we know what it is we live what it
is every day we've been living with this
[__] for years like you can't get to
tell us what racism is no no no no no
you don't really know you kind of
oblivious to it because this system is
set up for you like this but you can't
tell us what it is and that's what like
that's what my research paper is like no
we're not going to let you define what
racism is to us no you been you've been
trying to do it but we're not going to
let you do that no more God Bless
America they try all right JB thank you
so much thank you man a fun talk very
interesting appreciate it man yeah maybe
we'll do it again whenever I like to get
into that religion thing with you no no
it would that won't
happen all right man thank
you